So, now you've learned the layout of simple AppEngine
app that uses endpoints. You started out by getting
the project from your udacity's GitHub repository. However, there
are various other templates for you to use when
you create a Maven project. And these are called
archetypes. To create a new Maven project using an
archetype, open a console terminal window and change to
a directory where you want to build your project.
>From the command line invoke Maven by typing
mvn archetype:generate. Hit return. If this is the first
time you're doing this, Maven needs to actually
download some things to show you the available archetypes.
Now, we see all the different archetypes that
you could use. It's kind of a overwhelming list
and you can filter it. So let's see
what archetypes we've got for appengine. So I'll enter
appengine here. And we've got three here, three
appengine archetypes. So let's see what we've got for
endpoints. Okay, we've got two. And you can do
other filtering if you want. And the archetypes can
change over time. But I'm going to go ahead
and create a archetype using the hello-endpoints-archetype. So this
is similar to the Hello World endpoints project that
you got from udacity, but it has a little
more functionality and a little more pizzazz to it. So here we want
two. So I'm going to enter two and the take the default number 3. And
then the group identity is really the package name. So, I'm going to call mine
com.google.training, that'll do. And then, I'm going to
call mine the artifact can be training.
Take the default snapshot. The package is
com.google.training. Then it's a quick summary of what
we're going to do. Just press Yes and Yes. Okay, build success. So now, if I
explore my directory, I have all the files for my project. So now I can
go into Eclipse and import this project that
I just created from the archetype. Existing Project,and
there it is. That's my project. Training's a bit
generic so I'm going to change the name. New
Hello World. Don't worry about the errors, we'll solve
those later. Finish, Continue, and you see over here I
have my new Hello World project. And I could
just go ahead and deploy that right away to
local host. Let's do it. Oh no. Launching dev
server has encountered a problem, can't find Maven installation embedded.
All right, I forgot about that. You always have to
remember this when you get a new project, say okay,
then you go to run as run configurations. Then we
need to find the one that we just used and
we need to make sure that the Maven run time
is external, not embedded. Dev App server is now running.
Let's go to local host. Okay, I needed to refresh
the browser. And you see I've got the new, the UI
for the new project. Could also go look
at the endpoint APIs that are available here in
the API Explorer. This is also called the Hello
World API. Or a slightly different greeting. So we'll
call, let's call get greeting. Oops, don't know
what the ID is. List greetings, and here are
the greetings. So, it's up to you if you'd
like to go ahead and create that archetype and
explore the project. I leave that to you, but I do want you
to know that there's lots of
different templates available for creating Maven projects.